THANK ON TO ORDER HI GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
CURVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE A MALE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO SIX SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT FIVE SIX TWO
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS PLEASE GO TO OUR
WEBSITE -- WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR FOR OPPOSITION
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER AND -- ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL -- THAT NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE A NEW TO A READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK -- PLEASE
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON BEFORE YOU GIVE
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
-- ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
OTHER CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THIS ONLINE TOOL
-- PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENTS ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT WELL I WILL BE PRESENTING
FILE ITEM NINE AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- SANTIAGO BUT WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WHICH WILL HERE AND FILE ORDER
BEFORE WE BEGIN PRESENTATION
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF
THE CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR WIENER PRESIDENT
SENATOR BATES HERE SENATOR
CORTEZ THE SENATOR CAFIERO
MCGUIRE PHOTOBOOK SKINNER
NUMBER CASKEY HERE AND NUMBER
TWO SYNDICATED PRESENT I'M
SORRY BURKE SAID IS PRESENT
NUMBER PRESENT SIX OKAY SO
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUIEN
SENATOR MCGUIRE IS HERE AS
WELL RIGHT BEHIND YOU WHERE
PRESENT OKAY SO WE HAVE SEVEN
MEMBERS HERE -- WE HAVE A
A QUORUM AND BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS I'D LIKE TO TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- ARE
-- ITEM FOR EIGHTY SIX ONE ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUICK SILVA
-- ITEM SIX AB EIGHT OH THREE
BY SOMEONE OR BOERNER HORVATH
WHICH WAS REMOVED FROM CONSENT
BUT HAS BEEN PLACED BACK ON
CONSENT AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB ONE OH NINE FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY THERE'S A
CONSENT CALENDAR BUT WE SHOULD
BY CENTER BY CAL SKI TO MOVE
CONSENT -- -- MAN CONSULTING
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS FOR SIX AND SEVEN WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE BATES AYE BATES
AYE CABALLERO PROTESTING A
PROTEST THE AYE MCGUIRE OCTOBER
OCTOBER I SKINNER NUMBER
NUMBER I WOULD CASKEY HI WOOD
COUNTY ICE SIX THAT HASN'T SIX
VOTES WE WILL PUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- OKAY WELL NOW THAT
OUR FIRST AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO -- BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALKING
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR EIGHTY TO EXTEND
THE SUNSET DATE OF LEGISLATION
ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH AUTHORIZES THE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO AND SAN BERNADINO
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES TO
SECURE MIXED INCOME HOUSING
PROJECTS INCLUDING THOSE
TARGETED FOR MIDDLE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO
HELP PROVIDE FOR THE MISSING
MIDDLE THE LEGISLATION THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED LEGISLATION
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TO INCENTIVIZE THE HOUSING
STOCK THAT CAN MEET THE NEEDS
OF WORKING FAMILIES AND THE
MIDDLE CLASS AB FORTY TWO
PROMOTES HOUSING INVESTMENTS
TO AVAILABLE AVAILABLE TO
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF INCOME
STRATA AT NO COST TO THE
STATE TO THE DATE THE PROGRAM
HAS SHOWN MODEST SUCCESS IN
ONE PROJECT ACQUISITION AND
THE SUBJECT TO RESTRICTIONS
BELIEVE THAT EXTENDING THE
SUNSET WILL ENABLE THE PILOT
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS TO TEST
THIS OPTION THE TOOL IN TOOLBOX
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR
THE MISSING MIDDLE I HAVE MORE
TOP AS A WITNESS ON THE PHONE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND CHUCK CHRISTENSEN
WITH THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION IS ON THE LINE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL INFORMATION
IF MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
ON THE HILLCREST PROJECT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO
-- YOUR TO WITNESSES EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
-- IF YOU EXCEED YOUR TWO
MINUTES I WILL EAT UP TIME
FROM THE OTHER WITNESS SO
IF YOU COULD PLEASE -- -- BE
MINDFUL -- PRITCHETT AND WE'LL
GO TO YOUR FIRST -- WITNESS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I AM WE WERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE ARE THE ANSWERS AB FORTY
TWO AM AND SAN DIEGO LIKE MANY
-- MANY URBAN AREAS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I STRUGGLE TO KEEP
UP WITH THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
ITS RESIDENTS WE SPONSORED
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION FOUR
YEARS AGO TO PROVIDE A TOOL
TO HELP INCREASE THE STOCK
OF HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE
TO THOSE AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
ON THE CONTINUUM OF NEED
THE SAN DIEGO CITY COUNCIL
AND MAYOR TODD GLORIA ARE
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME HOW
HOUSEHOLDS AB FORTY TWO WILL
ENABLE THE CITY TO CONTINUE
TO USE ITS OWN RESOURCES TO
INCREASE HOUSING AT ALL LEVELS
WE KNOW THIS BILL IS NOT THE
ABSOLUTE PANACEA FOR THE ENTIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISSUE BUT
WE THINK THIS IS A MODEST --
BUT VERY GOOD LOCAL TOOL FOR
HOUSING AUTHORITIES TO HELP US
MEET OUR COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WILL GO TO THE NEXT TO A LEAD
WITNESS YES -- GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHARLES B.
CHRISTIANSEN WITH THE LAW
FIRM OF CHRISTIANSEN AND
STAFF ARE FOR IS GENERAL
COUNSEL THERE YOU GO HOUSING
COMMISSION AND WE'RE I'M
HERE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
GREAT THANK YOU
OKAY -- YOU'RE BOTH VERY
EFFICIENT -- WILL NOW GO TO
GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT IN
FAVOR AND SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY TWO -- AND -- ON ONE
-- AND I WANTED TO KNOW FOR
GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF SUPPORT AND AGAIN NOW IS THE
TIME ONLY FOR SUPPORT IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION THERE WILL BE A
TIME FOR YOU -- AFTERWARDS --
SO WE'LL START OUT HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS FOR EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY TWO IS SAYING
NINE -- WE WILL GO TO ROOM
THE TWENTY FORTY OR ONE TWELVE
I WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
CAN WE PLEASE GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE WILL WAIT UNTIL WE CAN
SEE REMOTE VERY OF ROOM ONE
TWELVE THING NO ONE -- WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MADAME
MODERATOR -- IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE FOR IN SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THEIR
LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK
IN THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION -- TO
AB FORTY TWO WE HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES -- TOM LEMON FROM
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND JEREMY WHITE -- FROM THE
STATE BUILDING -- TRADES SO
WE'LL START WITH MISTER LYMAN
AND AGAIN IT'S A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES SO -- MISTER LIMIT IF
YOU WANT TO TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
REMARKS TWO MINUTES -- SO THAT
YOU DON'T I GET A SIDE AYE
FOR MISTER WHITE THAT WOULD BE
GREAT -- SO MISTER LEMON YOU
MAY BE DONE -- THANK YOU --
CENTER WIENER AND COMMISSION
-- AS YOU HEARD OF TOM WOMEN OF
A REPRESENTING BUILDING TRADES
AND ALSO -- AN EXECUTIVE BOARD
FOR THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
-- CALL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB FOUR EIGHTY TWO WARD
UNLESS AMENDED AND I AND I'LL
CIRCLE BACK ON THAT I THINK WE
ARE I THINK I UNDERSTAND THE
BILL LITTLE PROVIDES FINANCING
FOR MIDDLE CLASS INCOME AND
THAT'S REALLY GOOD AND JUST BUT
WHAT IS NOT GOOD AND WHAT IS
NOT JUST THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE PROJECT WILL BE BUILT --
WITHOUT THE USE OF PREVAILING
WAGE FOR SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE THOSE TWO THINGS IN
COMBINATION ARE THE FUTURE OF
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD WITHOUT THEM
IS A SLAP IN THE FACE TO THE
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF MIDDLE
CLASS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS I
ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO SHOW
LEADERSHIP AND ADD SKILLED AND
TRAINED BEFORE VOTING AND IF
NOT PLEASE ME VOTE NO ON A.
B.
FOUR EIGHTY TWO -- JUST A
QUICK PERSONAL NOTE I GREW
UP IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STILL STANDS AND IS STRONG
AND BECAUSE IT WAS BUILT THE
WITH THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE BACK IN THE DAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR LINEMEN -- MISTER WHITE
I'M SORRY YOUR MICROPHONES
ON ON A PRETTY GOOD TURN ON
PLEASE TRY AGAIN IS THAT
WORK YEAH NOW THERE YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TODAY
-- THE OPPOSITE IS ABOUT THE
POLICY BEHIND THE FORTY TWO AND
A PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT TO
ADDRESS HOUSING THAT'S BECAUSE
SOME DEVELOPERS IN THE STATE
THE PEOPLE WHO BENEFIT AND
PROFIT FROM BILL SUCH AS THIS
AND MADE IT THEIR BUSINESS
MODEL TO BUILD HOUSING AND
MAKE THEIR PROFITS ON THE
BACKS OF UNSKILLED WORKERS WHOM
THEY CAN PAY THE MINIMUM WAGE
THAT'S WHY THEY OPPOSE A VERY
WORK PROTECTION LANGUAGE WE'VE
ASKED FOR IN THIS BILL IN IT
IN ANY OTHER BILLS THAT DEAL
WITH HOUSING THE INSERTION OF
SKILLED AND TRAINED LANGUAGE
WHICH MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH STREETS DESPERATELY
NEEDED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS SEVENTY TWO
PERCENT OF OUR SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND PROMISES ARE MADE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ONE
IN FIVE COMPANY FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM ARE EITHER EMANCIPATED
YOUTH OR RE ENTRANCE FROM
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THESE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PROVIDE A LIFETIME CAREER
IN THE BUILDING TRADES AND A
PATH TO THE MIDDLE CLASS TO
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO FOR WHATEVER
REASON OR NOT COLLEGE BOUND
WITH EVERY BILL THAT PROVIDES
RISK OF THE TRAIN WORKFORCE WE
GROW OUR PARTNERSHIP SYSTEM AT
NO COST TO TAXPAYERS BUT HER
BODY FOR A PUNISHABLE BILLS
LIKE THIS POLICYMAKERS COULD
CREATE WORK OPPORTUNITIES THAT
BRING POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS
OF ADDITIONAL REFERENCES INTO
THE CONSTRUCTION TRAINING
PROGRAMS LIVING ABOUT FOR
THOUSANDS OF WORKING FAMILIES
FURTHERMORE THESE REQUIREMENTS
HELP ENSURE THAT PROJECTS WILL
GET BUILT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
AND DISTANCE IN A VICE BALLAD
CONTRACTOR FROM COMING IN
FROM OTHER STATES TO BID THESE
PROJECTS AND EMPLOY WORKERS
FROM OUT OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT LANGUAGE ALSO PROTECTS
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE
CONSTRUCTION APPRENTICES FROM
BEING EXPLOITED BY SOME OF
THE DEVELOPERS IN THE STATE
I THINK IT IS OKAY TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE US
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
THESE IMPORTANT EVENTS ARE
FORTUNATELY NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL IT WILL BE A PART
OF THE PROGRAM THIS BILL
EXTENDS THIS IS ABOUT BEING
CONSISTENT ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING TRADES WE HAVE DECIDED
TO CONSISTENTLY REQUIRE LABOR
PROTECTION IN THE BILLS AND YOU
HOUSING THAT IS WHY WE OPPOSE
AB FORTY TWO TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
WHITE OKAY WILL NOW GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE DOLLARS I'M SORRY
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY OKAY SEE NOW WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE A SINGLE
ANIMAL ONCE ALL THE GOOD OF THE
PHONE LINES KIND OF MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE PROBLEM TO
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION -- TWO EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY TWO AND AGAIN IN NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB FOUR EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR
OWN NOW ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR
LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BUILT AROUND ONE
THE EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF
THE SALMON DINO IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ON BEHALF
OF THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
TRADES IN THE INLAND EMPIRE I
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND THE SAN DIEGO
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION AB FOUR EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU THIS IS
DAVID BEATING SECOND RECORD
FOR THE SANTA CLARA AND SAN
BENITO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE STAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
AND THE SAN DIEGO BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
BUT THIS BILL PUBLIC FUNDS BE
TO LIFT UP FAMILY SUPPORTING
APPRENTICESHIPS THANK YOU
MY NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CAROL CAN I MOVED TO SAN
DIEGO -- COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
FAMILY HOUSING CORPORATION
WE OWN AND OPERATE THE SECOND
LARGEST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPLEX IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO WE STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT Q.
-- UNLESS IT'S AMENDED
TO INCLUDE COVENTRY
BUCKLERS THANK YOU
THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- IS CRITICAL WHAT ROAD
SPRINKLER FITTERS LOCAL
UNION SIX SIX NINE YOU STAND
IN OPPOSITION THERE'S STILL
LINE NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
MY NAME IS JASON SHELLEY
I'M ON A PROGRAM IN SENEGAL
CAUGHT ON WHAT WORKS WITH
FORMERLY INCARCERATED WOMEN
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ORIGIN
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS TYPE OF
WORK IS NECESSARY TO REDUCE
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE I THINK YOU I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MATTER MODERATOR
WILL NOW BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE -- COLORS
ARE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS REGARDING AB FORTY TO
SEND RECORDS HOUSING THANK YOU
SURE THE I AM -- RELATIVE TO
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION COMMENTS
THAT WE HEARD OF HIM -- I'M
CURIOUS AND IF THE AUTHOR BE
WILLING TO RESPOND TO THIS -- A
CERTAIN RESPECT -- YOU KNOW THE
NOTION OF DOING AN EXTENSION ON
THIS PROGRAM AND THAT BECAUSE
OF THESE ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
SAID THE PROGRAM ITSELF IS
THE CERTAINLY ADDRESSING THE
NEED -- THAT SO MANY OF US
-- -- COMMITTEE ON THAT SAID
-- WITH THE LIMITED WITH A
LIMITED VOLUME OF ACTIVITY FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WAY TO PUT
IT WITH THE PROGRAM THUS FAR
AND GIVEN THAT IT'S A PILOT
-- I'M I'M I'M WONDERING WHY
FOR THE WORK FORCE PROTECTION
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN ASKED
FOR HASN'T -- YOU KNOW BEEN
AGREED TO IT SEEMS LIKE A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY PARTICULARLY WITH
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM MY OWN COUNTY ON
THIS INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH BUT
HAVING SERVED DOWN THERE --
SO RECENTLY -- I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING
FINANCED WITH PARTICIPATION
FROM THE KALLONI IN EVEN OUR
HOUSING AUTHORITIES -- PROJECTS
ARE SO OFTEN INVOLVING COUNTY
BOND MONEY IS TYPICALLY BY P.
L.
A.
CERTAINLY WITH WORK FORCE
PROTECTION SO I'M NOT SURE THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS ASKED FOR
WOULD HAVE ANY IMPACT ON MY
HOME COUNTY -- IT UNDERSTAND
THIS IS SORT OF A DISTRICT
BILL I WANTED TO YOU KNOW I
WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT THERE
ON THE RECORD DATE A I THINK
I HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING AND
KNOWLEDGE OF OF HOW THINGS
PLAY OUT AGAIN FOR MY OWN
CAMERA VENTURE IT JUST SEEMS
SEEMS LIKE THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD BE IMPORTANT BUT SORT
OF INCONSEQUENTIAL IN TERMS OF
ANYBODY HAVING TO MAKE THE HUGE
TRANSITION WE'VE SEEN SO MUCH
LEGISLATION COME THROUGH WHERE
IN ALL CITY WITH RESPECT WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT -- YOU KNOW
TO THE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND OTHERS
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES I TRYING TO
TO APPLY WORK FORCE PROTECTION
SORT SUDDENLY OR OVERNIGHT TO A
LARGE -- TOOLS LARGE OF SECTOR
OF THE EMPLOYMENT TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED IN AN
INDUSTRY -- IT YOU KNOW TAKES
APPROPRIATELY IS HAS BEEN --
TAKING SOME OF MY MY COLLEAGUES
BACK IN IN AND EVEN MYSELF AT
TIMES IN TERMS OF CAN WE GET
THIS DONE BUT I DON'T SEE THAT
QUESTION HERE THERE'S NO CAN
WE GET THIS DONE IN MY MIND
-- QUITE THE CONTRARY IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO OUT THERE AND AND TRY TO
MAKE IT WORK -- JUST LIKE THE
OVERALL PROGRAM IS IS IS SORT
OF IN THAT SPACE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK
UNTIL -- MR SURE I I DIDN'T
MEAN TO YOU KNOW TO MAKE A
LONG DIATRIBE OUT OF THIS BUT
-- I WANTED TO KIND OF FRAME
WHY I'M ASKING THE QUESTION
THE QUESTION REALLY IS JUSTICE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION OF -- WHY
NOT -- IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
-- GO IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
AMENDMENTS -- IN UNHEALTHY --
THE AUTHOR WOULD BE WILLING TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER FORTY
I KNOW THAT -- COUNTY SANTA
CLARA DOES HAVE A SUPPORT
LETTER AND THEIR RATIONALE ON
FILE I'M SORRY THEY'VE NOT TO
COMMUNICATE THAT TO YOUR OFFICE
OKAY -- I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO MAYBE TRY WILL BE ADDRESSING
THAT MY CLOTHES I I'VE GOT
SOME I THINK -- HARMONIOUS
LOTS TO YOUR YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU I CENTER ON BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS --
TYPE OF SO THE AUTHOR WHO'S
GIVEN ME -- HIS COMMITMENT
I TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD THAT
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE -- BUILDING TRADES IN
THOSE THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
CERTAIN PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THE BILL
DIED TODAY WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO OF VISIT THIS
BILL SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING BUT
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
-- ASIANS AND REVISIONS ARE --
WITHIN THE BILL WHEN IT GETS TO
THE FLOOR SHOULD GET THAT FAR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M CALLING TO ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON A.
B.
FOUR EIGHTY TWO BY CENTER BY
CAL SKI HI JOHN I JUST WANT TO
COMMENT THANK YOU THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
WANT TO THANK -- THE OPPOSITION
ALSO FOR ENGAGING -- AND I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND WITH THE
AUTHOR -- AND WITH OTHERS AND
MY APPROACH IN THIS COMMITTEE
-- THE -- AND I'VE I'M A
SUPPORTER OF SKILLED WORK FORCE
AND AND PROBABLY MY BIGGEST
HOUSING BILL EVER AUTHORED SB
THIRTY FIVE INCLUDES A SKILLED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS --
WE ARE I I THINK WE NEED TO
MOVE TO A POINT IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE CONSTRUCTION IS DONE
BY A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
A SUPPORTER OF IN SAM WHEN I
WAS IN POOR SUPERVISORS PL A WE
HAVE A CITY WIDE DE LA AND --
SERVICES CO WHICH I SUPPORTED
-- I WOULD HAVE BEEN THE AUTHOR
OF IT HAD I NOT LAST BEFORE
TO COME TO THE SENATE BEFORE
IT GOT DONE -- AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION
SO THAT ARE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO BE PART
OF THE MIDDLE CLASS -- SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO COMMUTE THREE
HOURS TO GO TO WORK -- AND SO
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
IN THE HOUSING THAT THEY ARE
-- BUILDING -- WE'RE GOING
THROUGH A TRANSITION PERIOD
NOW -- IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE
OF THAT AND WHAT IT MEANS THERE
IS A LOT OF CONFLICT AROUND
THE NOW AND AS I I SOUND LIKE
A BROKEN RECORD AND GET THE
SAME QUOTE TO THE PRESS EVERY
TIME I'M CALLED THAT WE NEED
TO GET THIS RESOLVED HAVE THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE TO
GET A RESULT HAVING DETERMINED
BY THE LEGISLATURE BY THE
GOVERNOR ON AND JUST GET THIS
DONE SO WE CAN TRANSITION AND
REALLY SCALE UP OUR SKILLED
WORKFORCE DRAMATICALLY EXPAND
THEIR APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT HOUSING
AND COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT
IN CALIFORNIA IS BEING BUILT
-- BY A SKILLED WORKFORCE IN
ALL REASONS THAT MEANS HAVING
APPRENTICES AND AND THIRTY
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE NOT JUST
IN THE BAY AREA RAMPING IT
UP EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE
-- AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
SKILLED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED
MORE AND MORE BECAUSE WE NEED
TO BUILD MILLIONS OF HOMES
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE BEING
PAID WELL -- AND COULDN'T LIVE
IN THOSE HOMES SELLING THE MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION -- -- YOU
WERE HAVING THESE FIGHTS ARE
BILL BY BILL NOW -- AND I'VE
TAKEN THE POSITION THAT THE
AUTHORS DECIDE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO HAVE SKILLED WORK FORCE
-- IN THEIR BILL SOME CONDOS
COMMITTEE WITH SOME WITHOUT
ON AND I DON'T AS CHAIR FORCE
THEM TO TAKE IT OUT OR PUT
IT IN -- BUT I WILL REITERATE
CAN THAT WE NEED TO GET THIS
DONE -- AND AND AND AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO RAMP
UP OUR SKILLED WORKFORCE --
AND DO IT COLLECTIVELY SO --
WITHOUT ALL THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY I KNOW THE AUTHOR
IS IN CONTINUAL CONVERSATIONS
-- WITH THE TRAITS OF BOTH
BACK IN HIS HOMETOWN AND
STATEWIDE AND I I TRUST THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE
-- AND SO -- MADAM CONSULTANT
YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I
THOUGHT SO MY APOLOGIES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE CLOSE
I THINK I DID MY CLOTHES
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH YOU AND I
REALLY WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE COMMENTS AS WE SENATOR
AMBER YES OF COURSE I HAVE
HAD SEVERAL MEETINGS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH ANYBODY
THAT WANTS TO HAVE AN INTEREST
IN ANY OF MY BILLS -- BUT I TO
HAVE BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THAT OUR OUR HOUSING DOES
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
PREVAILING WAGES AND HAVE
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS HOWEVER
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
ABOUT CREATING THE MUCH NEEDED
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING OUR STATE
NEEDS BY EXTENDING A VEHICLE
TO ACQUIRE INDEED RESTRICT
PROPERTY SUCH AS THE HILLCREST
IN SO WITHOUT THE AUTHORITY
TO FINANCES MIDDLE INCOME
PROJECT THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION COULD NOT ACQUIRED
THE ALREADY CONSTRUCTED
PROPERTY OF FORTY SEVEN UNITS
TWELVE OF WHICH ARE PERMISSIBLE
ORDER HOUSING NOW HOUSING HOLD
PREVIOUSLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
IN MY DISTRICT ALTHOUGH THAT I
ACTUALLY TOOK ON THE SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCIL WITH NO OPPOSITION
FROM THE BUILDING TRADES OR
OTHER COMMUNITY PARTNERS SO WE
DO NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONSTRUCT
FOR HOUSING IN OUR STATE AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH A MEMBER OF THIS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE FUTURE BUT WE
NEED TO PRESERVE THE HOUSING
STOCK THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
BEEN TO IN SHRINE AFFORDABILITY
FOR DECADES TO COME THIS BILL
DOES JUST THAT AND THE REASON
THAT I'VE COME IN I'VE STUDIED
THIS CLOSELY AND WE'VE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE
HAD TO COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT IT DOES NOT APPLY HERE
-- IS BECAUSE THERE IS NO NEW
FINANCING HERE THIS IS ABOUT
EXTENDING A SUNSET I KNOW THERE
ARE NO EASY BILLS -- IN EITHER
OF OUR HOUSES SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW THERE'S NEW PERSPECTIVES
THAT COME TO LIGHT THIS IS
EXTENDING AN EXISTING PILOT
PROGRAM TO TEST THE THEORY
OF WHETHER OR NOT EXISTING
AFFORDABILITY MECHANISMS FOR
THE PURCHASING ACQUISITION
AND OTHER ACTIVITIES ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO EXTEND
TO THE MIDDLE INCOME RANGE
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY ALLOWED
HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN ALLOWED
FOR THE LOW INCOME RANGE
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
LET THESE SERVICES IN SECOND
TEST THAT QUESTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ON ANOTHER
TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX FOR THE
PROVISION OF MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THAT
IS NOT RESPECTFULLY IN THE
OPPOSITION'S LOTTERY BEGINS
AT THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
PROVIDE PUBLIC FINANCING TO
DEVELOPING FINANCING HOUSING
PROJECTS EXCEPT IT DOESN'T DO
THAT AND WE KNOW IT DOESN'T DO
THAT BECAUSE BOTH OF OUR HOUSES
OF KEY THIS NON FISCAL THERE
IS NO NEW PUBLIC FINANCING
HERE AND SO FOR ME THE REST
OF THE CONVERSATION THEN IS
UNSUBSTANTIATED AND WHILE
I WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS NEW PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
THAT DO HAVE A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS
I DON'T BELIEVE IT IS
APPLICABLE IN THIS BILL I WOULD
WELCOME OTHER SENATORS ODD
COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS ON THIS IS
THIS IF THIS WERE TO APPROACH
THE SENATE FLOOR -- BUT AT THIS
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONOR I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SORRY FOR
ALMOST SKIPPING OVER CLOSE --
WITH THAT BENEFIT SUBSTANTIVE
WOULD YOU PLEASE OUR STATE
THE MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
SENATOR WIENER LET'S DO PASSED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR YES CORRECT
RIGHT FIVE FIVE WIENER AYE
BATES HI BATES -- CABALLERO HI
COPYRIGHT -- CORTEZ C.
BUILDING PROTESTING NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE A CHORE BOOK HI RICHARD
BERG SKINNER NUMBER HI NUMBER
I WOULD CASKEY HI CASKEY ARE
SIX OKAY THAT IS SIX VOTES
FOR A PROLONGED COUGH IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WILL NOW GO
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO -- EIGHTY
FIVE OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME
TO THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATORS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE OH TWO I'D FIRST LIKE
TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
TO AMEND THE BILL IN A WAY
THAT NOW MAKES THIS MEASURE
PERMISSIVE INSTEAD OF MANDATORY
I WOULD BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS UNDER
CURRENT LAW WHEN H.
AWAY HOLD SELECTION FOR ITS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IF THEY
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
RUN FOR OPEN POSITIONS THEY
MUST STILL GO THROUGH ALL THE
FINANCIAL PROCEDURES OF HAVING
THE ELECTION THIS PLACES A
HUGE BURDEN ON H.
AWAYS AND ULTIMATELY THE COST
FOR THOSE FUND NEEDED ELECTIONS
GET FUNDED DOWN TO THE
HOMEOWNER A FEW YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATORS PASSED A MEASURE
TO ALLEVIATE THE SITUATION BY
LOOMING LARGE HOAS DO A VOTE
BY A COMMISSION IF THE EXACT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO SIGNED
UP FOR THE RUN FOR POSITION
MATCHES THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS
OPEN UNFORTUNATELY THAT MEASURE
ONLY APPLIED TO HOAS WITH SIX
THOUSAND OR MORE UNITS SMALL
HOAS WERE LEFT OUT AB FIVE A TO
IS A SIMPLE MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT SAME ELECTION PROCEDURES
MAY APPLY TO EACH YEAR HAL'S
HOAS OF ANY SIZE I SHOULD
NOTE THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE ELECTION PROCEDURES
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
IF MORE PEOPLE SIGNED UP TO
RUN THAN OPEN POSITIONS THEN
THIS BILL DOES NOT COME INTO
PLAY A REGULAR ELECTION SHALL
HAPPEN IN ADDITION WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD GIVE HOMEOWNERS
AN ADDITIONAL NINETY DAYS
NOTICE ABOUT UPCOMING ELECTIONS
ON TOP OF THE EXISTING THIRTY
DAY NOTICE LASTLY ACCORDING
TO THE STAKEHOLDER DATA FOR
AB FIVE OR TWO THERE ARE ONLY
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIRST
SO SHE ISSUES WITH A THOUSAND
OR MORE UNITS IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING ONE PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL SIXTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
THE ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
-- FIFTY UNITS OR LESS TOTALING
MORE THAN THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
FIFTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE BUDGETS OF LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SO THE EXPENSE
OF THIS I NEEDED ELECTION COULD
BE SIGNIFICANT I'VE WORKED WITH
OPPOSITION BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND TODAY HERE IN THE SENATE
TO TAKE SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE WITH THEM
WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA PHONE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
MIKE VON AT THE L.
A.
COUNTY MAINTENANCE CORPORATION
AND TOM FREELY CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COMMUNITY MANAGERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU AS
A MEMBER AND I FORGIVE ME IF
I AYE MRS BUT ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES SIR
OKAY THANK YOU AND I'M SORRY
YOUR WITNESSES ARE THEY MAKING
COMMENTS OR TEST HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT THEY CAN MAKE
COMMENTS AS WELL BRITAIN'S
-- SO I HAVE TO THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES MIGHT BALK AND TIME
FREELY YOU'LL EACH HAVE UP
TO TWO MINUTES -- AND SO --
YOU MAY -- BEGIN MISTER ROCK
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THANK
COOPER TO NEGATED BY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MY NAME'S
MICHAEL VAUGHAN I'M A LONG TERM
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA AND SERVE ON
THE BOARD OF THE L.
ACCOUNTING MAINTENANCE
CORPORATION -- YOU KNOW WHERE
THE OTHER WORDS FOR ALEXION'S
BOARD OF DIRECTORS TWICE ONCE
UNSUCCESSFUL IN A CONTESTED
ELECTION AND MOST RECENTLY
LAST YEAR IN UNCONTESTED
ELECTION SB FIVE OH TWO
WILL BENEFIT ALL COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THERE RESIDENTS BY ALLOWING
ELECTIONS OF DIRECTORS BY
ACCLAMATION ONLY IN THE CASE
OF THE POND CONTESTED ELECTIONS
THERE BY ELIMINATING COSTS
OF CONDUCTING UNNECESSARY
UNCONTESTED ELECTIONS CURRENTLY
THANKS TO SB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR AS NOTED BY CIMBALOM
DAVIE'S ALLEGED BY ACCLAMATION
AVAILABLE ONLY TO THE LARGEST
SINCE THE ASSOCIATIONS WITH
NUMBER SIX ALBUMS RESPECTFULLY
I SUBJECT KASI NEEDS ARE
JUST AS IMPORTANT AND SMALL
ASSOCIATIONS LIKE MINE ALL
THE COSTS OF CONDUCTING AN
ELECTION MAY BE MINOR COSTS
AND SMALLER ASSOCIATION BUT
MINE ARE LIKELY GREATER ON
A PER UNIT BASIS IN THE ARE
IN THE LARGEST ASSOCIATIONS
ELECTIONS BY ACCLAMATION WILL
ENABLE BOARDS OF DIRECTORS
TO BETTER MANAGE H.
AWAY BUDGETS AND RESOURCES BY
FOCUSING ON BUDGET PRIORITIES
INCLUDING MAINTENANCE AND
WATER COSTS WHICH BENEFIT ALL
RESIDENTS OF ALL ASSOCIATIONS
WHICH IS GOOD LEGISLATION I
ALSO BELIEVE THIS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN DAVIES SUGGESTION THAT
WE WILL ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE MORE
RESIDENTS TO STEP UP AND RUN
FOR ELECTION TO THEIR COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS MAKING OTHERWISE
UNCONTESTED ELECTIONS CONDUCTED
FOR THESE REASONS I SUPPORT AB
FIVE OH TO ENCOURAGE THEM AND
MEMBERS TO ADVANCE THE BILL
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR FREELY YOU
MAY PROCEED GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOM
FREELY AND I AM THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COMMUNITY MANAGERS PRIOR
TO MY ROLE AS CEO AS EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF A MANAGEMENT
FIRM I PERSONALLY MANAGED OR
SUPERVISED MANAGEMENT OVER A
HUNDRED SITUATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND I CAN ATTEST
FIRSTHAND THAT THIS BILL WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS AND THEY'RE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ELECTED BY
ACCLAMATION -- IN AB FIVE OH
TWO WOULD ONLY COME INTO PLAY
IF THE ELECTION IS UNCONTESTED
AFTER ASSOCIATION HAS DONE
THE DUE DILIGENCE TO SOLICIT
CANDIDATES HAS SET FORTH BY
VOTING PROCEDURES THE CIVIL
CODE SECTION FIVE ONE ONE FIVE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES NOTICE
OF THE ELECTION AND NOMINATING
PROCEDURES TO BE GIVEN AT LEAST
THIRTY DAYS IN ADVANCE OF AN
ELECTION RECENT AMENDMENTS ALSO
ADD AN ADDITIONAL NOTICE NINETY
DAYS OUT FURTHER CURRENT LAW
JUST ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THROUGH LEGISLATION
SPONSORED BY THE OPPOSITION
PROHIBITS ASSOCIATIONS FROM
DISQUALIFYING CANDIDATES FOR
ANY REASON OUTSIDE OF THE FIVE
SPECIFIC ONES LAID OUT IN CIVIC
CIVIL CODE SKEWS ME SECTION
FIVE ONE HUNDRED NOTHING IN
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO WOULD REMOVE
THE HOMEOWNERS RIGHT TO RUN FOR
ELECTION NOR WOULD HE GET ANY
DECISION MAKING FOR DISCRETION
TO THE BOARD TO NOT HOLD AN
ELECTION IF IT IS CONTESTED IT
IS ONLY AND SOLELY IT'S ONLY
SOLD FUNCTION ON WHETHER THERE
ARE ENOUGH HOMEOWNERS THAT ARE
NOMINATED OR SELF NOMINATED
FOR CANDIDACY IF THE ELECTION
IS APPLE CONTESTED A FULL
ELECTION WILL ENSURE OCCUR IF
THERE ANY EQUAL NUMBER LESS
CANDIDATES IT SIMPLY DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO ENCOURAGE THE
TEN UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
SECRET BALLOT ELECTION WHEN
THE RESULT IS ALREADY CLEAR
I UNDERSTAND THAT OPPOSITION
BELIEVES THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ENABLE INCUMBENT DIRECTORS
TO REMAIN IN OFFICE HOWEVER
IN MY EXPERIENCE AB FIVE OH
TWO WOULD ACTUALLY ASSIST
IN GETTING NEW BOARD MEMBERS
SEATED AS OPPOSED TO CONTINUING
THE EXISTING PORT MAKE UP DUE
TO THE INABILITY TO HOLD AN
ELECTION OR IN SOME INSTANCES
ALLOWING EXISTING BOARD MEMBERS
TO A POINT FOR THE VACANT
POSITIONS WHICH IS MORE LIKELY
TO LEAD TO THE PROBLEM THAT
THE OPPOSITION IS WORRIED
ABOUT MEMBERS IN CLOSING AB
FIVE OH TWO IS A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION THAT WILL ENABLE
ELECTIONS TO OCCUR CANICE TO BE
SEATED AND HOMEOWNERS TO SAVE
MONEY ON ELECTIONS WHERE THE
RESULT WOULD NOT BE CHANGED BY
BALLOTING ALL WHILE ENSURING
THE NOMINATION PROCESS IS
THOROUGHLY TRANSPARENT AND
OPEN FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AIBO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
VALUABLE TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL NOW GO TO
GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY AND
THE FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT I SEE
NO ONE IN THE SENATE GALLERY
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
I SEE NO ONE EVER ONE TWELVE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
KIND OF MODERATOR -- COULD
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORTERS AB FIVE OH TWO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH
TO PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO
AND UPGRADE WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER PLATE
SHOULD BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW THE WOMAN WAS THE CHAIR
LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MATT CLAXTON I AM A MEMBER OF
THAT COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE AND A MEMBER OF
MY AGE AWAY FOR DIRECTORS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE IN FAVOR OF
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER NINE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY RAILEY I'M
FROM COLLECTED DURING OUR
FIFTY FIVE PLUS COMMUNITY
AND I AM IN SUPPORT
RIGHT HERE ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO KNOW
ONE MOMENT HERE
LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE IT
TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY AT THE FUTURE FOR
THE LINE NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD I MEAN
THEY'RE GREAT BEAR AND THE
ELEPHANT HAD THE BIG MANAGEMENT
WE MANAGE SEVERAL LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
IN AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION -- WE DO
HAVE WYNESS LEAD OPPOSITION
-- TESTIMONY TIME SIR FROM
THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
LAW -- YOU MAY PROCEED
IT'S TIME SIR ON THE LINE BUT
A MODERATE I MEAN WHEN IT'S
ALL FINISHED SHE I'M SORRY
HAD GOTTEN USED TO CHEER THE
SENATE PURPOSELY SCHEDULE THAT
ONE SPEAKER NAMELY ME -- IN
HOPES OF PRESENTING A COHERENT
SOMEONE MORE DETAILED STATEMENT
THAT WILL PAY WELL UNDER FOUR
MINUTES AND SO WE WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE OFFICER
FOR ACCEPTING ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE SEEKING
MAINLY TO MAKE THAT MEETING OF
BOARD MEMBERS BY AFFIRMATION
OPTIONAL RATHER THAN MANDATORY
THEN THERE'S THE POWER OF
THE INDIVIDUAL APPROPRIATION
TO ADOPT OR NOT ADOPT BUDGET
COULD FEATURE AND WILL INFORM
MEMBERS OF THE CHANGES PROPOSED
AND ADOPTED HOWEVER THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO OPPOSE THE FINAL
TWO HAND WRITTEN BECAUSE IT
WOULD PREVENT THE CANCELLATION
OF HOMEOWNER THE ASIAN MEMBERS
RIGHT TO VOTE WITHOUT NOTICE
AND WITHOUT THE RIGHT TO BE
HEARD IN OPPOSITION AT THE
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THE BILL UP
HERE IS TO MAKE THE BEATING OF
NUMBERS AUTOMATICALLY WITHOUT A
VOTE ASSEMBLY UPON THE FINDING
BY THE INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS
THAT THE NUMBER OF NOMINEES
IS NOT MORE THAN THE NUMBER
OF VACANCIES ON THE BOARD
NO REVIEW OR OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS TO COMMENT IN LOGO IS
REQUIRED BY THE BOARD BEFORE
THE VACANCIES ARE FILLED BY
ACCLAMATION GIVEN THAT THE ONLY
THREE WRITTEN TO ACCOMMODATE
THE AMENDMENT THAT HAS BEEN
ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR IT
MUST SET FORTH PROCEDURES THAT
ADDRESS THE THE EFFICIENCY
AT THE PORT IN THE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE EIGHTY L.
U.
WHICH IS BEFORE YOU HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION HAD BEEN FOUND
REPEATEDLY BY CALIFORNIA
COURT TV QUIZ I GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION THE ORGANIZATIONS
WHO POWER TO AFFECT THE LINE
OF ITS MEMBERS EQUAL AND IN
SOME CASES THE HE THE POWER OF
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT H.
AWAY ELECTION PROCEDURES
MUST THEREFORE PROVIDE
THE SAME PROTECTION THE
OTHER PROVIDE YOU IN PUBLIC
ELECTION INDEED THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS RULED
THAT THE FOURTH CITIZENS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO VOTE
MAY BE REMOVED THAT CITIZENS
MUST BE GIVEN THE RIGHT TO
BE NOTIFIED YOU TO BE HEARD
SO THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
AS WELL THE CONCERN OF OUR
STANDARD END OF THE DEAL HE
MAYBE IT BY HER THURMOND THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE SEATING THE
BOARD MEMBERS WITH THAT OF BOTH
OF THE MEMBERS ONLY IT NUMBER
ONE THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HOLDS A PROPERLY NOTED NEEDING
ECCLESIA DISCUSS ALLOW MEMBERS
TO COMMENT AND THEN TO VOTE ON
THE PROPOSAL TO THE IT REPORT
NUMBERS WITHOUT A NUMBER TWO
THE KNOWN AS THE SUCH A MEETING
SHOULD BE INDIVIDUALLY DELIVER
TO ALL MEMBERS AND SHOULD STATE
THE NAMES OF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE NOMINATED AND THE NAMES OF
ALL CANDIDATES BEING CONSIDERED
FOR BOARD POSITIONS AND THIRDLY
APALACHIN MEETING NOMINATIONS
OF ADDITIONAL CANDIDATES SHOULD
BE PERMITTED GET THIS RESULT
IN HAVING MORE CANDIDATES THAN
THERE ARE OPEN BOARD POSITIONS
IN THE ELECTION MUST BE HELD
BY ALLOWING THE THE DISALLOWING
THE NATION THIS WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE MORE PARTICIPATION BY
THE MEMBERS WHICH IS OFTEN AN
ISSUE WITH THAT MANY -- H.
AWAY SHE SO THE THE DIGITAL
MANAGEMENTS WOULD CONSTITUTE
A CHECK ON ANY ATTEMPT TO
ABUSE THE PROCESS AND WOULD
HAVE THE ADDED BENEFIT OF
THE DISCOURAGING MEMBER
PARTICIPATION IN THE GOVERNING
PROCESS AND WITH THAT --
WE ASK THAT YOU TAKE AND NO
GOOD AT THIS POINT AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY VERY OPEN TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR -- FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSED THE
ISSUES WE'VE RAISED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
WAS THREE MINUTES AND FIFTY
EIGHT SECONDS SO YOU HAD A
RIGHT ON THE HEAD -- WHAT
I'LL GO TO IT ANY ADDITIONAL
-- PUBLIC COMMENT I SEEN IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE A TO C.
NINE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NINE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ARE NOT
A MODERATOR COULD YOU QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION AB FIVE OH
TWO THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIDE
THERE ARE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU ARAMBULA COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY CARS OR
QUESTIONS ON AB FIVE OH TWO
CENTER BY CAL SKI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- HI AS STATED BY
A JUDGE CERTAIN THE OPPOSITION
I THINK WELL THE NOTICE THAT'S
PROVIDED BY IN THE AMENDMENTS
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS OR ON THE
FRONT END OF THE ACCLAMATION
VOTERS KNOW -- ATTRACTIONS
ONCE THE THE BOARD HAS
RECEIVED OR HASN'T RECEIVED
ENOUGH NOMINATIONS I WILL
NOTE THAT ONE OF THE OTHER
CONCERNS -- HE SAID THERE'S
ACTUALLY NO RECEIPT ONE GET
RECEIVES FROM THEIR H.
AWAY WHEN YOU NOMINATE SOMEBODY
SO PRIOR TO PROVE THAT YOU YOU
MADE THE NOMINATION AND I THINK
THE DISCUSSION THAT WAS MADE
IS ABOUT HAVING A HEARING WHERE
YOU DISCUSS AND ALLOW CON MEN
AND ALLOW NOMINATIONS BEFORE
THE BOARD TAKES AN ACTION ON
THIS AXSOME ACCLAMATION IS
ANOTHER SAFEGUARD I WILL NOTICE
ITS OUTLINE ON THE FINAL PAGE
OF THE STAFF ANALYSIS THIS
IS LAST YEAR OR TWO YEARS AGO
WITH A CENTER MORE LOCKED AND
I WAS WORKING ON THE GENERAL
ELECTIONS IN IN -- S.
B.
THREE TWO THREE WE WE FELL
ON THE SIX THOUSAND PERCENT
NUMBER BECAUSE OF ONE THAT WAS
IN HIS ISN'T SENATE-DISTRICT
BUT IT WAS IT WAS AND -- GIVEN
THAT THIS IS THE SIZE OF IT
AND AS THE AUTHORS INDICATORS
SO MANY OF THE HOAS ARE SMALL
SO I BELIEVE IT'S A LITTLE
PREMATURE TO BE MOVING THE BILL
NOW I KNOW I HAVE A CHANCE AND
JUDICIARY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AND WE'LL JUST NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR DID VETO -- CENTER
ROSS BILL THREE YEARS AGO AND
-- THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HELD A SIMILAR MAYES IS BILL
FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN IT CAME
TO THIS ACCLAMATION SO THERE'S
-- GOOD PROGRESS BEEN MADE
HERE BUT AT THIS TIME --
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
SENATOR CALLING FOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
BATES MOVE THE BILL EMOTION
BY CENTER BATES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
ON BURKE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN MEMBERS I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL -- SWIMMING IT LEAVES
THIS COMMITTEES GOING JUDICIARY
-- THERE ARE FOUR MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT ARE
ON JUDICIARY AND I JUST WANT
TO -- MAKE SURE THAT I'M NOT
RAISING FALSE EXPECTATIONS BY
VIRTUE OF THIS BILL -- GETTING
ELSE COMMITTEE WITH MY VOTE IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT IT AND
JUDICIARY THAT WE WON'T HAVE
EITHER CONCERNS AMENDMENTS OR
-- OTHER OTHER ISSUES WITH THE
BILL THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OKAY THING NOW WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR BATES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I DO WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE WILL WORK ON A RECEIPT
AMENDMENTS WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH -- OKAY
MADAM CONSULTANT YOU MAY STATE
THE MOTION ON CALDERON THIS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M SORRY THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR WINNER WINNER I'D BATES
ALL RIGHT BATES HI CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO I PROTESTED I
PROTESTED MCGUIRE MITCHELL A
BOOK I CHOPPER I SKINNER NUMBER
HI NUMBER I WOULD CAL SPEAK NO
PASQUINO SIX TO ONE OKAY THAT
HAS ENOUGH PHOTO PUT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY ONE EXTRA ITEM NUMBER
THREE -- EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES
AND SOME IRWIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AS DIFFERENT
AUTHORS SHOW UP -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES YOU MAY PROCEED
FAME IS A CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY ON AB FIVE SEVEN ONE --
THIS LEGISLATION IS ONE SMALL
PIECE OF A LARGER PUSH TO
MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE
IN CALIFORNIA IMPACT AND
DEVELOPMENT FEES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNDER DENSITY BONUS
LAWS CAN SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT
THE OVERALL COST OF THE PROJECT
AND ARE OFTEN PASSED ALONG
TO BUYERS IN THE FORM OF A
HIGHER HOPE OF OF HIGHER HOME
PRICES OR PREVENT PROJECTS
FROM GOING FORWARD THAT IS
WHY THIS LEGISLATION SIMPLY
PROHIBITS IMPOSING CERTAIN FEES
FOR DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS IT SIMPLY DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE TO DIS INCENTIVIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITH THE
DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION AS
WE SEEK TO ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS
TO MAXIMIZE AFFORDABLE UNITS
THAT WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE JENNIFER SACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SOME NUMBER
ON THE SACK YOU MAY PROCEED
SURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER SECOND HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE GOT A PROBLEM
WITH EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE THIRTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE SIX CREATE MORE UNITS
OF NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE MARKET RATE HOUSING
ALSO SPEAKING TO INCREASE
AND MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS CONTAINED WITHIN THE
DENSITY BONUS APPLICATION
REMOVING DUPLICATIVE FEES
WILL MOVE US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AS WE SEEK TO ENACT
POLICIES TO HELP THE FOLDER
STATE PERSISTENT HOUSING
CRISIS WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE GALLERY SEEING NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NINE -- WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES BUT A
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE YOU UP
ANY SUPPORT OF PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE STRUCTURE MEMBERS
OTHERS BOB NAIL REPRESENTING
FIELD STUDIES AND COMPANY
WERE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE WE
HAVE NO OFFICIAL -- OPPONENT
LISTED FOR TESTIMONY SO WILL
FIRST GO TO THE SENATE CHAMBERS
ANY OPPOSITION -- SEEN NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEN ON WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOT A MODERATOR QUEUE
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS BILL
OKAY I SEEN ON DO
I HAVE A MOTION
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE
-- AND SOME REMEMBER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THE TIME
TO PRESENT THIS LEGISLATION
AND RESPECTFUL REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU -- WITH THAT --
OUT OF CONSULTANCY REYES STATE
THE MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAYES THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WINNER WINNER
I'D BATES BATES -- CABALLERO
CABALLERO PROTESTING PARTISI
MCGUIRE MITCHELL BOOK I WHICH
OF A BUG EYED SKINNER AMBER
HI AMBER HI WITH CAL SKI WITH
HUSKY I SEVEN SEVEN ROADS IT'S
ENOUGH BUT WE'LL PUT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THEY GIVE
SAFE ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- I DO
NOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDIO
HERE OR SHOULD I NOT SEE HER
SO WILL GO TO -- S.
-- ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB ONE
ONE OH ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN NO ONE WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY ON EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I AUTHORED AB
TWENTY NINE TWELVE THAT UPDATED
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE FOR H.
OF WAYS TO PREVENT FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITIES AND THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW THIS BILL IS
A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP MEASURE
THAT DIRECTLY RESPONDS TO
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS FROM
THE STAKEHOLDERS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT OUR STATUTES
TO COMBAT FRAUD ARE CLEAR SO
HOAS CAN EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
THE LAW TO PROTECT THEIR FUNDS
RECENT AMENDMENTS -- PROVIDE
A SLIDING SCALE APPROACH TO
DETERMINE WHEN BOARD APPROVAL
IS REQUIRED WHICH WILL CAPTURE
ANY LARGE SCALE POTENTIAL
FRAUD AND WOULD IT COULD
ENCOMPASS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
HOAS OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT MAKING THE REQUIREMENT
OVERLY ONEROUS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY OR THOMAS WHERE
ATTORNEYS WHO LITIGATED H.
AWAY FRAUD CASES AND STACEY
DONNELLY WHO IS AN EXPERT
IN FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
FOR COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- OKAY MORE EARLY
LINDA SAYS THOMAS WHERE AND
STACEY DONNELLY YOU'LL EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES -- WE'LL
START WITH -- MISTER WHERE
IT SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE HE'S NOT
ON THE CALL THIS IS STACEY
DONNELLY I CAN START THIS RIGHT
YEAH THAT'S TOTALLY WILL START
WITH YOU YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STACY
DONNELLY I AM THE CFO OF
CONDOMINIUMS FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT I'M ALSO SERVING AS
A LIAISON ON OUR LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT COMMITTEE FOR THE A.
I.
MY COMPANY HAS PROVIDED
BOOKKEEPING SERVICES FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS FOR FORTY
SIX YEARS AND I'VE PERSONALLY
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE INDUSTRY
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AB
ELEVEN OH ONE IS TO PROVIDE
SOME CLEAN UP TO AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE WHICH WAS PUT
INTO LAW IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN NOW THAT WE'VE HAD
SOME EXPERIENCE WITH AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE IN ACTUAL PRACTICE
WE SEE SOME AREAS THAT NEED
FURTHER CLARIFICATION CURRENTLY
THERE IS A CALCULATION REQUIRED
WITH RESPECT TO TRANSFERS
THAT ARE ALLOWED BY A MANAGING
AGENT AND THAT CALCULATION
CAN CHANGE ON A DAILY BASIS
BECAUSE THAT RELATES TO BALANCE
IT AND THINK IT COUNTS SO
WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR IS A
MORE DEFINITIVE THRESHOLD IN
EIGHTY ELEVEN OH ONE THERE ARE
ALSO FURTHER PROTECTIONS ON
HOW HOAS INVEST THEIR MONEY
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRING THE
PROTECTION OF THE PRINCIPAL
AND THEN LASTLY I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT FURTHER PROTECTIONS
ARE PROVIDED WITH RESPECT
TO COMPUTER FRAUD AND FUNDS
TRANSFER FRAUD INSURANCE MY
COMPANY PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
A LOSS IN THIS ARENA AND IT
IS THE FASTEST GROWING LOSS
LEADER FOR OUR INDUSTRY SO
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
ON EIGHTY ELEVEN OH ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M TOLD THAT MR
WHERE IS ON THE LINE SOMEWHERE
MADAME MODERATOR TO YET HELLO
HI MOM I'M ON THE LINE OKAY
WONDERFUL WE FOUND YOU -- SO
-- YOU MAY PROCEED OKAY THANK
YOU UP AT THE MENTION MY NAME
IS TOM WHERE I'M CURRENTLY THAT
LETS THE CULTURE HE SAYS THE
ASIAN INSTITUTES CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION MANY BOB
WITHIN THE TURN YOU REPRESENT
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS FOR THE
PAST THIRTY TWO YEARS AND THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONLY MENTION --
I HAVE A SPECIAL PURSUING AND
-- FUND RECOUP IN FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
VIA -- INSURANCE -- PROPERTIES
LIKE TBILISI FONG CLAIMS AND
THE STATE HE MENTIONED -- THIS
BILL BUT A LOT OF STUFF BUT I'M
GONNA FOCUS RIGHT NOW ON THE
BEATPORT CLARIFICATION USUALLY
WITH THE INSURANCE ASPECT OF IT
AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE INITIALLY
REQUIRED TO HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS THAT THAT MAINTAIN
COVERAGE TO INSURE AGAINST THAT
BY DIRECTORS OFFICERS AGENTS
EMPLOYEES AND THE MAN'S GAUGES
AND THE MAPS GAUGING FOR FOUR
EIGHT YEARS AGO THE L.
A.
COVERAGE BUT THERE IN THIS
MARKET THERE'S DIFFERENT TYPES
OF COVERAGE THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AND IN FACT IN MOST CASES
MOST ASSOCIATIONS HAVE EASIER
ACCESS TO THIRTEEN OTHER TYPES
OF INSURANCE WHICH IS DEPLOYED
THIS HONESTY COVERAGE AND
CLIMB LOST COVERAGE AND THIS
BILL CLARIFIED THOSE TYPES
OF COVERAGE ARE SUFFICIENT
PROVIDED THAT THEY MEET THE
COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN THE BETWEEN
LIKE TWELVE AND SO BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT THING AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE COVERAGE SO
THERE'D BE SUBSTATION FINANCES
ARE NOT AT RISK AND FOR THAT
REASON WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS WERE IN SUPPORT WERE
ASKED PEOPLE PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT THERE
ANYONE IN THE SENATE GALLERY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN OH
ONE SAYING THAT I'M WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE -- WE SEE
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES GOT A MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT FOR AB ELEVEN OH ONE
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ALIVE
AND ALL ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU OF COURSE
WHAT I NINE I HAVEN'T RIGHT
YES HI THIS IS KIMBERLY LILY
AND I'M FROM COAST TO DRAIN A
FIFTY FIVE PLUS I THINK FUSION
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SHARED PART
OF THE TEARS COMING OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
MANAGERS OR THANK YOU ARE
INTENDING PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT HANDER PLEASE GO AHEAD
AT FIVE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD
JENNIFER WATER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU -- WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN A ONE I HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS IDENTIFIED MARJORIE
MURRAY -- IS VERY YOU MAY
PROCEED GOOD MORNING SENATOR
WIENER HAD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN THANK YOU THE CENTER
IS SUPPOSED TO A.
B.
ELEVEN OH ONE FOR TWO
REASONS THE FIRST IS IT HAS
NO ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
AND THE SECOND IS STILL
PERMITS PROPERTY MANAGERS
TO CO MINGLE MONEY FOR
MULTIPLE ASSOCIATIONS SO IT
IS UNCLEAR HOW AN INDIVIDUAL
BOARD IS SUPPOSED TO REVIEW
WITHDRAWAL OF FIVE THOUSAND
TO TEN THOUSAND WHEN THEIR
MONEY IS NEXT UP WITH THAT
OF MULTIPLE OTHER HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS WE'VE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO GET AN ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS CONTROL
AN ESTIMATED THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CASH ALL OF THE
COLLECTED FROM AN OLD BY
HOMEOWNERS THERE ARE A FEW
LEGAL CONTROL OVER THE MONEY
EXISTING LAW NOT YOU LAW BUT
EXISTING LAW FOR THE LONGEST
TIME HAS REQUIRED THAT IT BE
KEPT IN A FEDERALLY INSURED
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION EIGHT
EIGHT ELEVEN OH ONE CHRONICLES
THE ASIANS WILL CONTINUE TO
KEEP ALL THE MONEY IN INSURED
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT GAMBLE
WITH THE ON THE STOCK MARKET OR
OTHERWISE HAVE RIPPED HOWEVER
THIS LEGISLATION CONTAINS
NO ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THAT OUR THIRTY ASIAN
BOARDS AND THEIR ADVISERS
DON'T PUT IT IN THE STOCK
MARKET OR DON'T GAMBLE WITH
THE TEN OTHER RISKY DENTURES
SO WHY ARE WE CONCERNED BECAUSE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION BOARD
ALREADY BREAKING THE LAW TEN
HOMEOWNERS HAVE NO ROLE FOR
THE BULLS LEGAL RECORD THE
BOARD OF ONE CENTRAL COAST
ASSOCIATION REGARDING THOSE
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
ITS RESERVES ARE NOT FEDERALLY
INSURED BANK AND HANDED IT
OVER TO MORGAN STANLEY HOW ARE
UNINSURED THE BOARD PLANS TO
HAND OVER ANOTHER HALF MILLION
IN RESERVES EGGMAN BROKERS
EVEN BETTER DECISIONS ARE
DOCUMENTED IN BOARD MINUTES SO
THIS IS NOT YOUR THING THE LION
RELATING TO YOUR SMALL GROUP
OF HOMEOWNERS ALL RETIREES
MAKING THE BOARD FOR THE BANK
STATEMENTS AND THE BUSINESS
TERMS OF THE DEAL BUT THE BOARD
REFUSES TO PROVIDE EITHER IN
FACT THE BOARD HAS SOME OF THE
HOMEOWNERS TO WITHIN ONE HOUR
HEARING WRAPPING THEM WITH
THEIR REQUEST FOR FINANCIAL THE
BOARD IS BEING ADVISED ON ME BY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THIRTY A LAW
FIRM IN THE STATE SHE BECAUSE I
HAVE NO AFFORDABLE WAY TO STOP
THE BOARD FROM HANDING THEIR
RESERVE MONEY OVER TO BROKER
DEALERS PLEASE HOMEOWNERS HAVE
RESORTED TO FILING A COMPLAINT
OF ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN THEIR COUNTY SKINNER
COUNTY AND THE DA IN TURN
HAS REFERRED THE MATTER TO
THE LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT
HOMEOWNERS NEED MORE FLEXIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE MEANS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THIS KIND OF
RENEGADE BOARDS THE CASE HERE
AB ELEVEN ON ONE COOPER NO
SUCH PROTECTION WE PROPOSED
THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
PROVIDE IS NOT CERTAINLY NOT
HOMEOWNERS THEMSELVES CAN BRING
CLAIMS OF VIOLATIONS IN THE
SUPERIOR COURT FOR IN THE SMALL
CLAIMS COURT DR THEY BRING
OTHER CLAIMS FOR VIOLATING
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE CIVIL
CODE IN THE CORPORATION'S CODE
UNTIL THE BILL IS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
SO THAT HOMEOWNERS CAN TAKE
DIRECT ACTION TO PROTECT
THEIR MONEY WE MUST CONTINUE
OPPOSING THE MEASURE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THE NEXT TO NINETY TWO
AMANDA STILL BUT MEANWHILE WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE NO ON THE MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU RICARDO IS
EXACTLY FOUR MINUTES SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND IT'S
-- I DO HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE SENATE GALLERY SEEING
NONE -- WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE BUT SEEING KNOWING
THERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN A ONE
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT
ZERO ELEVEN OH ONE SEES PRESS
LINE AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CALLERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR MAYBE ELEVEN OR ONE OKAY
SEEING NINE TO HAVE A MOTION
MOTION BY CENTER CABALLERO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY OFFICE
HELD A NUMBER OF MEETINGS
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WE
TRIED OUR BEST TO RESPOND
TO THEIR CONCERNS INCLUDING
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THIS COMMITTEE -- REGARDING
CONCERNS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
ANOTHER PORTIONS OF THE DATA
STERLING ACT I WOULD DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION TO PAGE SIX OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH
DESCRIBES HOW MANY CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE OPPOSITION'S
FOCUS ON PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
LONG BEEN EXISTING LAW OR THAT
PREDATE EITHER OF MY BILLS
OR ARE ACTUALLY ADDRESS BY AB
ELEVEN NO ONE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT A CONSULTANT WE PLEASE
STATE THE MOTION AND CALL
THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
OH ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE BATES
AYE BATES AYE CABALLERO AYE
CABALLERO CORTEZ C.
BY POTENTIALLY MCGUIRE
MITCHELL ABOVE THE CHORE BUG
I SKINNER NUMBER HI NUMBER
OF CASTING HI WITH HEALTHCARE
SEVEN IT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
WILL PUT THE ITEM ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SENATORS THEY
WILL THEY'LL GO TO -- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE -- EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARDIO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE MEMBERS
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SOME OF
BILL SIX THREE FOR A MEASURE
THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BY ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO EXTEND THE AFFORDABILITY
TERM FOR FUTURE HOUSING UNITS
THAT QUALIFY DEVELOPER FOR A
DENSITY BONUS BEYOND FIFTY FIVE
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW WAS CREATED AS A TOOL
TO HELP ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY INCLUDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
A DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPERS ARE
GRANTED AN INCREASE IN DENSITY
OVER CITY SUNTAN CITY AREA THE
INCREASE INTENSITY CONCESSIONS
AND INCENTIVES INCENTIVES OUR
AIM TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CURRENTLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO ADOPT INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES THAT
REQUIRE DEVELOPER TO INCLUDE
A PERCENTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON SITE OR PAY AN IN
LIEU FEE TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ELSEWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT
LAW IF THE DEVELOPERS SUBJECT
TO INCLUSIONARY SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENT AND THE DEVELOPER
LACKS TO UTILIZE THE DENSITY
BONUS THEN THE AFFORDABILITY
DIRECTORATE DURATION I'M SORRY
THE AFFORDABILITY DURATION
FOR RENTAL SET ASIDE UNITS
UNDER BOTH PROGRAMS WOULD BE
FIFTY FIVE YEARS IN SOME CASES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES REQUIRE
LONGER AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS
THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE LAST YEAR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FINALIZE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ITS INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE WHICH REQUIRES THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING SET ASIDES
AND RENTAL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
TO BE AFFORDABLE IN PERPETUITY
AB SIX THREE FOUR CLARIFIES THE
FOR THE UNIT AND DEVELOPMENT
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE THE COVENANT CAN BE
LONGER THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS
IF THE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE REQUIRES A LONGER
PERIOD AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IS BIANCA
SINGLE WITH THE L.
A.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF REGIONAL PLANNING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
NOW GO TO -- BIANCA SIEGEL --
AND SUPPORTS -- YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND TO THEIR BUDGET IS BIG
THIS MORNING I'M THE ARCHITECT
ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL PLANNING FOR THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE L.
A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KOREA BURKE AT
LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST I HAD
JUST EXPLAINS SB SIX THIRTY
FOR A LITTLE WHILE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE OURS TO
EXPAND THE AFFORDABILITY
TERM FUTURE HOUSING UNITS
CREATED UNDER STATE MOBILE
HOUSING PROGRAMS TO LONGER
THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS BASED
ON OUR OWN LOCAL ORDINANCES
THE HOUSING RIGHT THAT THE
COMPLICATED NO EXCUSE IN L.
A.
COUNTY IN THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS A TECHNOCRATIC STEPS
TO ADDRESS THAT BY PASSING A
NUMBER OF GRAPHICS FUNDAMENTALS
TO SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOLUNTARILY EXPAND THE CLUB
BEYOND FIFTY FIVE YEARS WHICH
IS A CRITICAL TOOL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND IT DOES NOT
AFFECT A JURISDICTION THINK
OPENLY DOWNING IN ORDER TO
CREATE A PUBLIC APOLOGY JUST
ABOUT TEXT BUT ONE THAT WOULD
HAVE FAR REACHING POSITIVE
BENEFITS AND STABILIZING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AVAILABILITY
IN SHORT WITH APPLICABLE
ON AFTER YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- OKAY IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX THIRTY FORCING NINE
ROOM ONE TWELVE SAY KNOWING
THEY'RE NOT A MODERATOR TO YOU
PLEASE SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE IN THEIR
OWN AND OPERATE IT WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX THIRTY FOUR THIS PRESS
ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW
AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO MONEY Q.
OKAY WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE SENATE
GALLERY SAY NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
FIFTY NINE -- IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSITION
TO TO -- -- THIS ITEM MADAME
MODERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AB SIX THIRTY FOUR THIS PRESS
ONE ZERO WE WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB SIX
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN THERE -- NOW
IN AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO MANY Q.
THANK YOU WILL BRING
THE ITEM BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I
DO HAVE A QUESTION IN REGARDS
TO THE APPLICABILITY OF THE
BILL AND JUST WANNA -- -- I
READ IT IS -- RENTAL UNITS --
AND I'M ASSUMING THAT WE'RE
NOT REQUIRING ANYTHING WELL I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE FIFTY
FIVE YEARS ON -- HOMEOWNERSHIP
UNITS MOSTLY BECAUSE THEY
PROHIBIT THE HOMEOWNER FROM
BENEFITING FROM THE INCREASE
IN THE -- IN THAT PRICE OF THE
HOME AND IN OTHER WORDS OUR
INVESTMENT IS NOT REAL -- IN IN
A HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
SO COULD YOU -- CLARIFY WHETHER
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AB -- A
RENTAL UNIT AS OPPOSED TO A
FOR FOR FOR SALE UNIT THAT IS
CORRECT THIS IS FOR RENTERS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I TO BE A MOTION MOTION BY
CENTER CABALLERO -- AND --
AND SUPPORTING THIS BILL I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD WE'VE HAD
ISSUES I KNOW IN LOS ANGELES
ALSO IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
ELSEWHERE -- WE'RE WE HAVE
-- THESE UNITS ARE COME OUT
OF THE DEED RESTRICTION AND
IT CREATES CHAOS -- FOR THE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THOSE UNITS
AND THAT IT PUTS THE CITY IN
A POSITION FOR WHETHER IT'S
TRYING TO BUY IT -- AND SO I
THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
-- TO CREATE MORE FLEXIBILITY
THAT THE CITY'S ALREADY
APPLYING A LONGER TIME PERIOD
YES SUCH AN APPLIED IS DENSITY
OUR UNITS IS ALSO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AND --
WITH THAT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY CENTER CABALLERO -- YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND APPRECIATE THE QUESTION IN
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING THROUGH UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES WHEN IT COMES TO SEEN
OUR ON HOUSE NEIGHBORS AS
WELL AS EVERYTHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE A CREATING A SPACE
IN WHICH HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT -- AND AS RENTS CONTINUE
TO GO UP AS PEOPLE CONTINUE
TO TRY TO REOPEN SAFELY AND
DO EVERYTHING NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE DIGNITY FOR THEMSELVES
AND FOR THEIR FAMILIES HOUSING
REALLY IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THAT CONVERSATION AT THIS
IS A THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS DETRIMENTAL TO THE WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIANS IN NEED
SB SIX THREE FOUR IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ADD TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TOOLBOX TO ADDRESS
THE SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM INSULTING YOU MAY STATE
THE MOTION CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER CARILLO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS SENATOR
WINNER WINNER HI BATES Là MÙT
IT'S NOT BURNING CABALLERO HI I
CORTES PROTECT THE AYE MCGUIRE
MITCHELL BOTH THE TROUBLE NOW
SKINNER NUMBER NUMBER I SKI
WITH HUSKY HI FIVE -- OKAY
DISCOVER THAT'S TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR YES OKAY THAT
HAS NOT TOTAL PUT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU OKAY
WE'LL GET OUR FINAL BILL ITEM
NINE AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO ALL BE
PRESENTING THAT'S ALL I'LL ASK
OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES
-- TO PRESIDE OVER THIS ITEM
THE NEW YORK
THANK YOU ARE FINISH WIENER
PLEASE PRESENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M NOT A MIXTURE
OF COLORS A SUMMER SANTIAGO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR CLARIFIES THE
OBLIGATION OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING AND ALL HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
RELATED ACTIVITIES THERE
BEEN RECENT REPORTS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE NOT THAT
I'M NOT ADEQUATELY TO FILLED
-- THERE -- IF SUPPORTERS
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHERING FAIR
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS TO ENSURE
ALL AGENCIES ARE -- PUBLISHING
THE SCHOOL AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
CLARIFIES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST ADDRESS RACIAL INTEGRATION
AND SEGREGATION PATTERNS --
IN ADDITION TO MORE GENERAL
FAIR HOUSING ISSUES THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ADDRESSING
HOUSING INEQUITIES AND ACTIVELY
PLANNING FOR A MORE INTEGRATED
FUTURE THE PRIORITIZE FOR
HOUSING -- WE HAVE A AS
EARLY WITH THIS TODAY SAN
DIEGO STUDIO WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
WHO IS JOINED BY ON YOUR
LAWLER -- AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WRITER
THANK YOU THEN WILL LEAD TO
A WITNESSES -- IF CASTILLO
-- PLEASE PERCENT AND IS IT
TELECONFERENCE YEAH MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
LEAD OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HELLO KAREN
LEONARD MY NAME IF YOU THINK
I FEEL ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE
AB THIRTEEN THEREFORE BUILDS
ON ITS PREDECESSOR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SIX WHICH IS A
FAIR HOUSING BILL ENACTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT REQUIRED
PUBLIC ENTITIES INCLUDING
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING A AFFECT EACH IN THEIR
ACTIONS RELATED TO HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
SSH USE THAT GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES MYSTIC ACTIVE STAFF
DID MANAGE FROM SEGREGATION
DR INCLUDES THE COMMUNITIES
EQUAL HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
ADDRESS INVESTMENT IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS AND
PROTECT RESIDENTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT THE AFH OBLIGATION
IT'S CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT DIVISIONS
ARE UNDERTAKEN IN A MANNER
THAT IS MENTAL HEATH PATTERN
WHICH HAS HISTORICALLY DENIED
MEANINGFUL HOUSING CHOICE THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR PROVIDE CLARIFICATION
AND STRENGTHENS THE REQUIREMENT
BY EXPLICITLY REQUIRING THAT
JURISDICTION'S INVENTORY
OF HOUSING BY SPEAKING WITH
THE AFH OBLIGATION REQUIRING
JURISDICTION TO LOOK AFTER
HOUSING ISSUE THROUGH BUT
THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL I'M
REQUIRING JURISDICTION TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT HISTORICAL CONTEXT
WHEN ASSESSING CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS FOR FAIR HOUSING
ISSUES AND FINALLY REQUIRING
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE EXPLICIT
GOALS OBJECTIVES AND POLICIES
RELATED TO AFH THIS IS THE
RIGHT TO FILL THAT ENSURE
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
MEANINGFULLY IDENTIFYING AND
DISMANTLING HOUSING POLICIES
THAT HISTORICALLY SEGREGATED
OUR COMMUNITY WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- I BELIEVE THE
TECHNICAL -- QUESTIONS WOULD
REMAIN FOR COMMITTEE DISCUSSION
IF WE NEED TO CALL AND MISS
LAWLER IS THAT CORRECT SENATOR
WIENER I YES YOU TO MISS
LAWLER HERE FOR -- ANSWERS ONE
QUESTION HEARING BECAUSE THERE
ARE IS THAT CORRECT THIS LAWLER
YEAH THAT'S CORRECT OKAY GREAT
THERE ARE NONE LIFF OF C.
CALL ANOTHER WITNESSES THAT
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AND I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY THEN
WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
I DO NOT SEE ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE THEN WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE PHONE MATAMATA
READER WILL YOU QUEUE UP FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE THREE OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE IT BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW THE
WOMAN ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR
BY NUMBER FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
THIS IS MARK SPIRES OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS JACK IF YOU WOULD
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE WANT
TO EXTEND THE COMMENT OF
THE LEAD WITNESS AND GRANT
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING SHARE SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS AJ HUDSON AND I AM HERE
REPRESENTING PUBLIC ADVOCATES
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND WISH TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU YEAH
AT THE TIME ADAM HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU THEN WE WILL GO TO THOSE
WHO MAY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD WITNESS SO I LOOK IN THE
GALLERY I DO NOT SEE ANYBODY R.
I.
IN THE GALLERY WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY LOOKING AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
THERE ARE TEEING UP TO TO
OPPOSE THEN WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES THAT A MODERATOR
AND PLEASE OPEN THOSE FOR
THOSE WHO MAY WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION BABY THIRTEEN OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW
AT THE TIME AND I'M SURE
WE HAVE NO MONEY Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ON ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT WISH TO
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS
SEEING NONE I'LL GO BACK TO
A SENATOR WIENER ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
FOR CLOSE I THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR SPECTRUM
THEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS I'M SORRY
WE HAVE A MOTION OH I'M SORRY
DID I INCLUDED NOT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL SO MOVE
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND WE'RE
I THIRTY TOMORROW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMISSION COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR WINNER
WINNER I'D BATES NO BATES NO
COPYRIGHT I COURTESY COURTESY
FIVE REQUIRED MCGUIRE I OF
CHIU ABOVE SKINNER NUMBER ALL
RIGHT NUMBER FIVE WHAT KASKY
HI WOOD COUNTY I SIX TO ONE
WELL HOLD IT OPEN ARE YOU I
BELIEVE FOR THOSE EVERYONE
HAS VOTED NOW CENTERS
SKINNER IS NOT HERE TODAY
-- -- SO I BELIEVE THAT --
WITHOUT BORDERS COMPLETES
BILL WITHOUT OKAY THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH RUN
BASED HER FOR PLAYING OVER
THAT ITEM I WILL NOW GO BACK
ON AND WE WILL OPEN -- THE
ROLE THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- WE'LL START WITH
THE CONSENT AGENDA -- MADAM
BOTTOMITEMS SO KEEP THIS CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
FOR SIX AND SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
SIX TO ZERO SENATOR CAFIERO HI
I MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
EIGHT ZERO THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS APPROVED I WILL GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THE CALL FOR OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WORK THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO SEVEN
ACQUIRE RIGHT MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER SEVEN OH IS THAT
THOSE OUT -- ITEM TO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAVIES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY CURRENT BUT SIX
ONE SEVEN ACQUIRE HI SKINNER
SEVEN A ONE OF THOSE OUT OF
ITEM NUMBER THREE PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE SOMEONE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE SENATE MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER EIGHT
ZERO LET THOSE OUT -- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC SORRY SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE TROUBLE OF I'M
SORRY THE TROUBLE WITH NOW
SKINNER SIX TO ONE CINEMAGOERS
MICROPHONES ON YOU GUYS I YES
OKAY -- THE BILL'S OUTS ONE
ORDER TO WINNER SO I WANTED TO
ADD ON SHE DIDN'T CALL ME I WAS
I'M NOT VOTING ON FIVE NINE I'M
A NO VOTE ON SITE OKAY SO --
-- AND YOU WERE SERVICE CENTER
BATES VOICE NOW ON EITHER SO
SENATOR BATES NOT VOTING TO
NOW YES YES SO WHAT IS A SIX TO
TWO SIX TO TWO BILLS OUT THANK
YOU SENATOR WHEN I GO TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT -- CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN A ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER IT
TO ZERO THE BILL ITSELF AND
FINALLY WILL OPEN UP I DON'T
THINK I'M NINE IS ALREADY
OUT SO SO MADAM CONSULTANT
EVERY NOW COMPLETED THE ROLE
ON ALL ITEMS YES OKAY -- THAT
COMPLETES OUR HEARING TODAY
I WANT TO THANK ALL MEMBERS
AND EVERYONE INTENSIFIED
-- WITH THAT THE COMMITTEE
ON HOUSING IS ADJOURNED